so let's start with wheeler
all right um he proudly publicized
a letter refusing help from federal
officers to address the violence
in portland zack if you would show my
screen here
this is his tweet he says today i sent
this is uh from 23 hours ago
so from yesterday today i sent this
letter via email to realdonaldtrump
declining his recurring offer to aid
portland by sending federal enforcement
to the city
and the letter reads uh begins dear
president trump
yet again you said you offered to aid
portland by sending in federal law
enforcement to our city
on behalf of the city of portland no
thanks we don't need your politics of
division and demagoguery
portlanders are onto you et cetera et
cetera et cetera
so uh as one commenter noted uh in
response to this this is zayed jalani uh
it's like wheeler is a double agent for
trump he's certainly
he's certainly acting as if to promote
uh
the likelihood that trump will get
reelected
uh given given what actually those of us
who are here
know to be true which is in part and
we've talked about this many
times already on on the podcast portland
is being used
as a as a bludgeon on both sides by the
mainstream media to to a large extent
it's just
it's either not being covered at all by
the mainstream media on the left
or when it is it's at those moments when
there is a far-right presence in the
streets as well
and then they can truth truthfully claim
uh that extremists on both sides
had it out as happened a week ago
um today i think it was um and of course
on the right the mainstream media
insofar as
um it exists outside of fox but fox
included
um talks about the the exact opposite it
only talks about the violence
um and and never never discusses any
possible legitimacy to
uh to the protests uh that we're seeing
but
the fact is downtown portland is
during the day looks like
a former city i don't i don't like the
term war zone because i think that that
evokes something uh
very particular that i'm not sure i know
enough about
all of the intricacies of to to say a
lot about but
um at the end of may
just as many businesses downtown were
preparing
to open up after months of covet
lockdowns
the protests started the violence began
at a regular moment every night shortly
thereafter and have
and those riots have happened every
single night uninterrupted for i think
it's more than 90 days
i believe there has been one
interruption there's been one
interruption there's been one
interruption
after the after the feds were pulled
after governor brown
negotiated two nights ago
um there was one night and there was
speculation about what it might be and
it turns out that what we're going to
talk about soon here
may have something to do with the actual
reasoning but i'm not sure we know
okay uh so uh i mean as
as viewers regular viewers of this
podcast will be well aware
um stores are vandalized uh many have
been boarded up
and closed since then there's been
nightly violence
uh homeless encampments are spreading
even further than they were previously i
mean all the west coast cities
have had a problem with homelessness um
for a very long time
um there's garbage in the streets
there's increasingly human feces in the
streets and not just that being thrown
by
idiot rioters um but actually it's just
it's just
literally becoming a cesspool and it
makes a person wonder how anyone who
calls himself a leader
uh could possibly let this happen to his
city this is this is
a beautiful city it's been it's been
beautiful
open to everyone replete with culinary
and cultural
and nature experiences and this is just
a disaster
so we see in the oregonian
on august 26 business owners reporting
being ever more frustrated
on august 27th uh we see i guess
you could put this up very briefly um
we see a report that uh 70
the portland business alliance and 70
other business and civic leaders
were on the phone with mayor wheeler on
thursday morning to discuss his plan to
revive downtown
um in which one of the things in this
piece is wheeler also said wednesday
let's see wheeler also said wednesday
that ending nightly violence and getting
our community back on its feet would be
a major priority for the city and
something he believed was a necessary
prerequisite to the economic recovery of
downtown
well them's easy words there's no
evidence that he's doing anything
anything to that end and then well
in fact he is doing exactly the opposite
he is treating the knightly riots
as if they have some legitimacy and you
said earlier the protests
might have some legitimacy i want to be
very careful the anger that fuels the
protests
yes comes from a legitimate place i
don't think these protests have any
legitimacy anymore they have
almost yes they have lost any legitimacy
they might once have had
by um not doing anything to stem the
violence that arises from the violence
is predictable
and that means that everybody who signs
up even the people who aren't being
violent
are signing up for something that leads
to violence that's
the responsibility is on them some
people are flocking there in part
because it's an excuse for a street
party there's no other place to do it
so but mayor wheeler's behavior i'm just
guessing here i've been very busy with
unity stuff
am i right that his behavior has made
the protesters
enthusiastic about mayor wheeler himself
that they are very pleased with his
behavior
they love him he's he's completely on
their side wait no
let's see where have we seen this before
like every time this happens yes at
evergreen yes every place else when you
have a weak leader
who pretends to be on the side of the
protesters
they still aren't going to love you they
still don't they're never going to love
you ted so how about stand up to them
and stop this so zack
um show my screen here we have oops um
you don't have to um i don't think you
need to um this is just
you know this is video of protesters
going into the lobby of
uh wheeler's condo presumably it says
apartment i i doubt he's a renter but if
he's lucky maybe he is
um in which they demand that he resign
abolish the police by 2022 with no tech
or private replacement
and a lot saved resources to bipoc
communities and city services
so you know another classic move from
the playbook of
i'm sorry but just witless protesters
you can't have both of those things
you can you can't both resign and
abolish the police by 2022
and finally they're saying it they're
actually saying it abolish
not defund abolish the police by 2022
with no tech or private replacement
yeah wow you know what he should say in
response to this
no yeah uh thank you but no
get out of my building stop it
in every regard and yes i am sending in
reinforcements
and no we are not going to be violent
with you unless you force our hand
yeah it's uh i mean it's totally
predictable
and the fact is here's here's what
wheeler is clearly missing
he um has a vast population of people
who now have every right to fear that
this
is going to come into their
neighborhoods and do who knows what
they've been
harassing people shining bright lights
into their windows cursing at them
demanding that they come out into the
streets now they're in wheeler's own
building
right so portlanders have a very real
reason to fear
that this knightly riot phenomenon will
come directly to them
at home right that means there will be
an
awful large fraction of the population
of portland
that would be grateful to have this
reigned in finally it has no legitimacy
it is it is announcing the fact that it
is
uh vile and irresponsible literally we
have people
throwing feces at police officers
um so there would clearly be a great
deal of support if he would just behave
like a mayor now
will they say that he's part of a
fascist crackdown
if he actually has the police do their
job and and arrest law breakers
sure takes them to jail of course they
will totally predictable
on the other hand will a large fraction
of the population of portland breathe a
sigh of relief that finally governance
is doing what it is supposed to do
what society depends on it doing of
course there would be right and because
he only hears the vocal part
yeah right the vocal part is the tantrum
right this is a tantrum and and he is
responding to it
because the adults are being quiet
waiting for him to do his job and the
fact is
do your job and the adults will support
it it's guaranteed
yeah so he's supposed to be the adult
you know when when you elect a mayor
you're
you're electing an adult in part uh to
act and you know this isn't a perfect
analogy a mayor isn't a parent
but what everyone probably has seen
the screaming toddler in the supermarket
who is having a meltdown because they
can't get the thing that they want
and most people have probably also seen
the parent say no
no you can't no you can't and finally
cave
what does that do it results in the
screaming toddler
very very briefly being quiet but what
that toddler has learned
is that tantrums work that is what is
happening here that is bad parenting
that is bad mayorship that is bad
leading in every regard you don't cave
to tantrums you just
you just don't do it and you know it's
not that
anyone will be perfect in this regard
and there are some situations where oh
my god this is exactly the wrong moment
okay
you little brat you little rioters
whatever it is i'm going to have to give
you this thing right now but you can be
damn sure
that once we get to a place where i can
enforce
good behavior i am going to do so fairly
and justly and you are going to learn
that this does not pay
why are we letting rioting and looting
and violence pay why would you do that
if you actually care about the city if
you actually care about society if you
actually care about democracy
you don't you're either not thinking it
through
in any way and frankly he's had plenty
of time
or you actually don't care about the
city or society or democracy so which is
it
[Music]
you